[Applause]
what soup
you
it's Charlie this is gonna be my
Mandalorian episode for video there was
all kinds of Easter eggs so we'll break
it down if you're new to the channel I'm
doing videos for all the episodes be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a weekly merch giveaway
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet so go do top 10 WTF
and Easter eggs as we go along starting
with number 10 the title and the
inspiration for the episode so the
episode was titled sanctuary it was
meant to be in episode where they go on
vacation for a couple of months as you
would expect things do not go as planned
but the episode itself is based
completely on the plot of Seven Samurai
you could also say magnificent seven but
Magnificent Seven was kind of a remake
of Seven Samurai and a little bit of
hidden fortress most longtime Star Wars
fans will recognize that those Akira
Kurosawa samurai films were the basis
for the original Star Wars trilogy so
they're going for some really deep cut
ester eggs here the episode did a great
job of showcasing just how much they can
do with that baby Yoda puppet on set
practically they use a little bit of
special effects to sweeten it but for
the most part it's a practical puppet
that they use on set
there was also an episode of Star Wars
the Clone Wars that did this exact same
plot from this episode called bounty
hunters but Dave Filoni ran that show
dave felonio so works on this show with
Jon Favreau so no surprise that there's
always a lot of Clone Wars Easter eggs
and episodes if you've never watched
those samurai films Seven Samurai is
basically a group of samurai that are
hired to protect a village that have to
teach the village how to defend itself
against a group of Raiders but number
nine the episode begins on the village
on a planet called sore again which is
brand new to Star Wars they created it
for the TV show the villagers are mostly
farming krill to sell to the local
market it's used to create those blue
drinks that you see them drinking later
in the episode in those vats if that
wasn't clear the leader of the village
is O'Mara
you probably recognize her from
Westworld season 2 or maybe the Twilight
movies this is a big callback to the
baby Yoda joke with him eating the Frog
when her daughter tries to catch one and
fails they pay it off later in the
episode when baby Yoda teaches them how
to catch it like a ninja
[Music]
their village is rated by a bunch of
creatures from Klaatu Wien if you're not
familiar with that planet those aliens
actually showed up a little bit in the
original trilogy and back an attack of
the clones but you haven't seen them a
whole lot before number eight back on
the razor crest things were a little
more chill baby Yoda won't stop playing
with all the buttons in the cockpit and
the Mandalorian starts yelling at him
you start to get a better sense for his
level of intelligence in his personality
when he knowingly starts messing with
the Mandalorian by flipping the buttons
after he tells him to stop he's like a
little kid who won't stop messing with
the door lock buttons or the window
controls on a long family car trip but
when the Mandalorian is weighing his
options for a place to hide out for a
few months it's a lot like the scene of
Han Solo trying to find a place to hide
out from the Empire after they fled Hoth
and Empire Strikes Back and just like an
empire Darth Vader finding them at Cloud
City the same thing happens to the mando
and baby Yoda on sorghum the bounty
hunters start to find them he drops a
big easter egg for a new hope when he
calls baby Yoda a little womp rat later
in the episode he tries to get
bull's-eyed by a womp rat by one of the
other bounty hunters - the thing about
womp rats though is that they're local
to Tatooine which implies that the
Mandalorian has been to Tatooine before
for those of you wondering if they'd
ever travel there on the series we
haven't been there yet on the
Mandalorian and they're mostly going to
new planets but don't be surprised
because Tatooine is also in the Outer
Rim territories because most of the
episode was them in chill mode they also
used it as an opportunity to show you
how much baby Yoda is mobile and could
go around by himself most of the time
we've only seen him being carried around
in that bassinet or carried in the
Mandalorians arms but he's deceptively
intelligent and almost seems like he has
teleportation powers with the way he
just shows up magically behind the
Mandalorian anytime you're not watching
him number 7 inside the alien Cantina
there's a huge Star Wars rebels Easter
Egg you all probably recognized when
baby Yoda is walking around just taking
in all the sights
everything looks huge to him because
he's so small he passes by this giant
cat whose mouth is bigger than his
entire body
that's called a loft cat it's local to
loathe all from the Star Wars rebels
series that's where most of that series
took place and speaking of Star Wars
rebels and Star Wars Clone Wars stuff
showing up on the mandalorian series
remember all that stuff happened way
back before
or the original trilogy this is
happening after the original trilogy but
Dave Aloni himself implied that we would
be seeing characters from those original
series Clone Wars and rebels showing up
on the Mandalorian in live-action form
he didn't say which characters but
obviously it's going to be different for
every different Disney plus live-action
series so for instance the obi-wan
series is going to take place between
Episode three in Episode four where
ahsoka is much younger it's much more
possible for her to show up on that
series than it is for her to show up on
the Mandalorian number six the
Mandalorian versus Cara dune we meet
cara dune Gina Corrado's character you
all probably recognized her instantly
she's been doing press all year for the
show they've been hyping her up as one
of the big characters of the new series
we learn about some of the special
tracking technologies that the
Mandalorian has built into his helmet
when he goes to find her thinking that
she might be there for them there's
probably a whole bunch of other secret
weapons that he has built into his suit
that we'll see in future episodes but
they wind up throwing down Gina Carano
mostly known for being an MMA fighter
before she became an actress so of
course they cast her and they're gonna
give her a big fight scene I was hoping
that there would be some masters of
Terra Cotta reference just because it's
such a deep cut but they mostly just
brawl the Mandalorian tries to use his
flamethrower again he really really
likes that flamethrower he's used it in
every single episode but then baby Yoda
shows up like a ninja slurping on his
soup to break the tension do you want
some soup we learned a little bit about
Cara doones backstory she says she's an
ex rebel shock trooper who was cleaning
up Imperials after the Battle of Endor
when she named drops going after ex
Imperial warlords those are basically
the generals in the admirals left in the
appear old fleet after the Empire or the
remnants of the Empire fled to the outer
rim to become the first order that'll be
important for later in the series
because Giancarlo Esposito is playing
someone who used to be an imperial moth
who was in charge of an entire sector
the sector that they're flying around in
now on the Mandalorian series then
number five we get our big Boba Fett
Easter Egg when the two villagers ask
him if he's not a Mandalorian and he's
just wearing their armor that's actually
an Easter Egg for Boba Fett and Jango
Fett neither one of them were actual
Mandalorians just people who wore
Mandalorian armor he kind of explains
their logic later in the episode part of
their code is that they never take their
helmet off or else you can't
put it back on that's basically your
sign that you're quitting being a
Mandalorian and if you go back and you
watch Attack of the Clones you see Jango
Fett walking around through most of that
movie without his helmet on there are a
couple exceptions too when they can take
their helmet off I don't know if he's
taken it off in the presence of the kid
yet but I'm assuming that he will do
that before the end of the series
Mandalorians are also allowed to take
their helmets off in the presence of
their significant other someone that
they're married to or mated to for life
or their children that's why I think the
big payoff at the end of the season you
know us maybe see him take his helmet
off will only be for the kid but the two
bumbling villagers that come searching
for the Mandalorian is a bit of a hidden
fortress Easter egg and it's also a big
callback to r2d2 and c3po taking the
perspective of two low level characters
to get across a whole bunch of
exposition they go back to the village
there's a couple funny moments with the
kids playing with baby Yoda and then
eventually Cara Doon in the Mandalorian
go and find that the Raiders half at a
TST and try to call things off the
villagers aren't having it so number
four they train the villagers to fight
this is really where you get to the
Seven Samurai montages during the film
preparing the village for this big
Raider attack the Mandalorian arms them
all with weapons from the razor crest in
surprise their leader O'Mara
is a crack shot they imply that there's
some secret history that she has on the
show some crazy backstory that they're
not telling you
Cara Doon drops an Empire Strikes Back
reference talking about damaging the
legs of the 80s T then they said they
have to set a trap for it this is also a
big reference to return of the Jedi
where you have a bunch of low tech
people like the Ewoks trying to fight a
bunch of high tech Imperials number
three the Mandalorian and Cara doon
versus the Klaatu in Raiders they take
out a giant chunk of them but they
weren't there to kill all the Raiders
they were just there to get them all
riled up so that they would follow them
back to the trap that they had laid at
the village when they blow up the tent
with that charge and all those big vats
that's basically them blowing up all of
their beer so to speak so yeah that
would definitely piss them off the
special effects for the a TST were great
my only disappointment with all those
scenes is that you never actually got to
see inside the cockpit of it like you
would see inside Empire Strikes Back my
guess is is that just for budgetary
reasons maybe in a future season they'll
go for full-blown eighty eighties at
some point number two the big fight at
the village taking down the Imperial
Walker it was actually
decent fight scene for being so short
but like I said the whole thing here is
that it's meant to be a reference to the
Ewoks fighting the Imperials during
Return of the Jedi so they're not meant
to be really amazing fighters after they
defeat them the Mandalorian decides he's
going to leave baby Yoda with the
village and they kind of play it like
maybe he's considering staying for a
brief second but it's only halfway
through the series and we know there's
gonna be a season two so of course he
was never going to stay at the village
there's a little bit of chemistry
between him and the woman O'Mara and he
explains that if he takes his helmet off
he can never put it back on again you
learned a little bit more about his
backstory during this episode like he
says I was about their age the little
kids when I put the helmet on for the
first time the Mandalorians took me in
and they were good to me that also lets
you know that you don't need to be born
into one of the Mandalorian clans to
become a Mandalorian but number one the
new bounty hunter almost kills baby Yoda
right as he gets the kid in his
crosshairs they cut it so that you don't
quite see what happens but you hear the
blaster shot so you do wonder if he's
dead for just a second but then you get
the reveal that Cara Doon got him from
behind it's also a bit of a callback to
him calling him a womp rat bullseye womp
rats in the t16 young Luke Skywalker on
Tatooine would be proud the Mandalorian
realizes that he has to take the kid
with him because not only will he always
be in danger his presence in the village
will also endanger all these people they
make for a second like he's gonna offer
Cara Doon a spot on his crew but then
they go their separate ways
saying until we meet again which will
probably be in season two because Cara
Doon Gina Carano was posting pictures
from behind the scenes while they're
filming season two a couple weeks ago
they've been a couple faints where you
think that he's gonna take new crew
members on but if you think about it
there's really only space for two two
and a half people inside that cockpit
including baby Yoda so it's not like
he's gonna be flying around with a giant
crew like you would see on the
Millennium Falcon in the original
trilogy the synopsis for Episode five
next week just says that he's going up
against a rookie bounty hunter so that
might wind up being bill burrs character
yes bill burr is playing a character on
Star Wars the Mandalorian but have you
spotted any other big Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them in the comments below I will be
doing more bonus videos for the
Mandalorian this weekend so leave all
your requests in the comments too if
there's a big question or a special
video that you want me to make next week
is also going to be big for Marvel
trailers
DC movie trailers so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
those videos when I post them I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post my next
Mandalorian video everyone click here
for my brand-new baby Yoda Mandalorian
history video and click here for my
Mandalorian episode 3 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I have spoken
you
[Music]